Lyall Stephanie let me ask you first of
all what you made of the verdict last
night I think him
deep down I thought it was going to go
that way obviously I had no way of
really knowing that bearing in mind that
was the initial decision which is then
acquitted and obviously overturned and I
think I said to people at the time going
into this we were well aware that there
would be a counter appear on the mass of
what last night's decision was which is
why you know I was perhaps a bit
nonplussed when the actual decision came
out and the other thing of course for us
is all those Stephanie has some Italian
language background white dome and in
that courtroom it's obviously a very
tense it's read out very quickly and it
actually takes a few seconds for for us
or me personally to even get a
translation of what the decision is so
and Stephanie what do you make of Amanda
Knox saying already there's no way I'm
coming back to Italy they'll have to
drag me off kicking and screaming I
think we're in a difficult position at
the moment because there are so many
steps in this system that it's not been
confirmed it's not the end and as law
said it could have gone either way
yesterday and I was quite prepared for
that especially seeing as it will go to
another level again however without
knowing what the final answer is going
to be it's difficult to know how
anyone's going to feel or react and
really when it comes down to it if they
are found guilty at the very end of the
case and she doesn't come back here then
that's going to be for Italy and America
to to kind of decide what they're going
to do do with that because as I said
previously if they're convicted and they
are guilty of murder they need to be
somewhere not just free in America or
Italy so must be difficult for you
though this has been going on the best
part of seven years now mm-hmm and still
it's not over yeah
absolutely yeah I've said before that
you know the way that Meredith was
killed is obviously horrific we've not
really had a chance to properly grieve
her because of this whole process has
been going on so long there's obviously
been so much attention on the defendants
and the case itself rather than Meredith
is the victim and yeah absolutely you
know the fact that it's in a foreign
country a lot of it's obviously in a
foreign language we're having to read
interpretations of stuff secondhand and
on top of that the fact that it's been
been as you say sort of knocking on in
seven years now and the next verdict in
this is going to be spring 2015 makes it
very difficult for sort of you know
finally draw a line under things and
move on meanwhile of course Meredith
Kercher your sister is almost forgotten
as you say in all of this it's all
become about Amanda not particularly if
she gets to see this what would you say
to her I don't know that we have
anything specific to say to anyone this
in question at the moment but in general
with regards to you saying about
Meredith being forgotten I think she has
been forgotten very much so in this case
because it does very much focus on the
trial rather than the victim at the
moment however there are a lot of people
out there who still send messages still
donate to the fund still talk about her
we're very much in touch with Meredith's
friends and as a family we will remember
her together so she's definitely not
forgotten but I think that the focus has
been shifted in the case and in the
media form actually as law said how
horrific this Crimea is what's actually
happened to me is the fact she was only
21 and it could happen to someone else
just as easily I think that's almost the
most important part to remember that
actually we need to find out what
happened you see very measured about
this this was your sister we have a
woman who's been convicted twice now her
murder sitting on the west coast of
America saying I'm not coming back I'm
not going to serve another day of this
28 and a half year sentence
how's that made me feel well sorry gonna
say um I think part of the reason we've
we've tried to remain measured about it
as you say is because I think we were
made quite early on that this could be a
very lengthy process I think as everyone
who's been following the case and any of
the details of it is where it's a very
intricate complex case and scenario of
what perhaps happened that night there's
certainly a lot of lot of question marks
I suppose at the moment still over what
precisely happened and from our point of
view you know we very much supported
that as I said before the prosecution
and the legal team the science they've
taken on it and the decision that
they've made so from our point of view
while we've fully supported on them and
we're well aware that it could have
taken some time decisions could have
gone either way you know and it's it's
difficult to sort of 100% expect one
thing to happen or the other and I think
you kind of have to sort of sit almost
across the middle of those two until
there is a final conclusion on it really
okay I ask you both a final question do
you think Amanda Knox and Raffaele
siliceous too killed your sister and do
you think either of them will ever end
up back in jail that's a very difficult
question for us to answer at the moment
because as I said there are still so
many things being investigated needing
to be confirmed that we aren't judges
we're not jury and we're certainly not
detective so it's difficult for us to
know what's fact what's fiction other
than what we are told and that is all
that we can go by it obviously suggests
that that is the truth and that they are
guilty seeing as it's been upheld again
this time but equally it was overturned
last time so we may never know exactly
what's happened but given the fact that
the Italian legal system is so thorough
and there is another stage we would hope
that they will be able to find out even
if not exactly what happened that night
just to be 100% sure who is guilty
do you think I'll ever go to jail ah
solid Siam you know of so Lots being
said at the moment of extra dish you
know if if last night's decisions upheld
in spring 2015 as I said before I'm
surprised if if America didn't cooperate
with an extradition you know fair the
mutual agreement on this an America seek
to extradite criminals from other
countries themselves I'd find it strange
if they didn't cooperate in that that
sense and obviously situ himself being a
an Italian national already in the
country and then already had his
passport taken from him I don't I don't
see how you could have somebody
convicted of what as I said is such a
horrific crime we're not just talking of
you know a drunk driver here killing
somebody I can't see how somebody
couldn't go to prison for that